hey Chris slick was there for a year all
these things happened and now he's gone
that's not the story this is the story
of a company that was in trouble that
needed to do some things that hired a
leader the leader had a boss so let's
think of him as a division president
which he was and the leader of the
larger organization there's all these
other cable channels Warner Discovery
all kinds of things they own CNN CNN is
just one think of it as a division well
guess what the initial headlines are
turns out that you're seeing over this
weekend are not the whole story The
mainstream media is sticking together
and all the people at CNN are saying
yeah it was Chris Licht he was the issue
well let me tell you like the Kennedy
assassination like Russian interference
in the 2016 election like the war in
Ukraine I'm going to show you that the
initial headlines not only don't have
the whole story but they're not
necessarily all correct